so thank you for coming to the
celebration of the visual arts it is
really wonderful that the Yale Center
for British art has opened on a special
Monday so that we'll all be treated to
an inspiring conversation on the history
of exhibiting and collecting abstract
art I'm always reminded of a claymation
film that maybe some of you have seen
called closed Mondays and it's about
these clay characters who go to the Art
Museum on Monday and have a wonderful
time with nobody there no staff no one
watching them well I am in no way
implying that your clay characters but I
am suggesting that on Monday we can have
a wonderful time at the Yale Center for
British art so I know it was an
incredible undertaking to bring together
such remarkable members of our artistic
community and I thank the Ale Center for
British art the Alumni Art League the
African American Cultural Center the
University Art Gallery and of course the
Yale Center for British art for
tonight's panel and for the reception
afterwards this idea originated I in the
Yale alumni Art League and I think was
Michael McKenzie and Nicholas Lewis did
a great job of taking that idea and
bringing it to fruition so Thank You
Miko I know Nicholas was called away to
a family funeral but I really appreciate
both of their work so we're going to
hear discussions today about the history
and experience of producing curating and
collecting abstract art and the panel
will feature great artists and scholars
Kevin Beasley and William Williams two
exceptional artists who graduated from
yells MFA program at the School of Art
susan khan our dean for the Arts in Yale
College pamela joiner a leading
collector and philanthropist whose
modern and contemporary art collection
has reframed the art world's
understanding of its
history Courtney Martin a scholar and
professor at Brown University who
received her PhD in the history of art
from Yale I should mention that Courtney
is about to become the deputy director
and chief curator of dia Art Foundation
and some congratulations on the new
position so Yale has a long history of
supporting art we recognize that art
collections can capture history social
change and art can help sort who shal
conversations about our society the
students and faculty at the Yale School
of Art always contributed their voices
and vision to such important discussions
our courses in the Department of the
history of art are some of the most
popular on campus so I know that all of
you tonight share an appreciation for
the vital role of the Arts and I thank
you for being supporters of the Arts at
Yale one of the great things about
teaching at Yale and I have taught in
the psychology department for many years
three decades is that we have this great
teaching these great teaching tools
sitting right here on Chapel Street on
either side of Chapel Street in our art
collections and one of the things I used
to do in my introductory psychology
class was to send students over to
either the Center for British art or the
University art gallery with assignments
like see what you can find out about the
way mental health and mental illness
were understood by looking at art and
they would come back they've discover
something and they'd come back with
something to share with our class and so
for me it was always incredibly
gratifying that we had these collections
at Yale and they could become teaching
tools throughout the curriculum so I'm
now happy to introduce Amy Myers the
director of the Yale Center for British
art she is a wonderful leader scholar
and teacher herself she began
her work here at the center in 2002
although she is a graduate of Yale's
doctoral program in history of art she
initiated the creation of the center's
conservation plan and guided this
centers through the completion of a
three phase building conservation
project the most comprehensive to date
really
Riaan visiting and bringing back to life
Louis Kahn's masterpiece
she has significantly expanded the
museum's role as a leading research and
as a leading educational institute in
the history of art and in culture and at
the same time she's strengthened the
center's exhibitions and publications
since the center reopened last May amy
has introduced the collections and
resources of it to many new students and
to our faculty the center has seen a 30%
increase in attendance as compared to
the same period in 2014 so we're all
very fortunate to have Amy as our leader
and I would like to introduce her to you
now but probably someone who needs no
introduction to this group Amy my
thank you Peter for that lovely
introduction and welcome to all of you
on this evening I would like to
reiterate Peters thanks to Miko and to
Nicholas for organizing a very special
panel additionally we are deeply
appreciative to Peter and to Marta for
their support for this evening excellent
event as well tonight's program is
supported by the rotor Pritzker fund for
lectures on modern British arts and it
is the second in a series of five
honoring the great gift of Rhoda's
collection to the center that collection
really sets us in new directions in
underpinning our ability to collect
modern art in very new and important
ways and evenings like this
I hope will become much more common in
our programming over the years to come
this evening we also recognize the work
of a London volunteer miko McGinty who
organized an exhibition at the center as
an undergraduate and adore
professionalize has designed numerous
publications for our institution most
recently enlightened princesses Caroline
Augusta Charlotte and the shaping of the
modern world the exhibition of the same
title is on view this evening in the
second floor galleries and given the
importance of Women's Day I think it apt
that perhaps you take a look I think
you'll find it to be a very important
forum exhibition our modern and
contemporary collection is mounted up
third four galleries and is open to
viewing this evening as well I now I'm
delighted to welcome back to the center
as Peters indicated Courtney Martin
assistant professor and art of art and
architecture at Brown University editor
of four generations
the joiner Ephrata collection of
abstract art and this evenings moderator
as a graduate student at Yale Courtney
was an active and beloved member of the
center's community working particularly
as a research assistant on an exhibition
entitled art and emancipation in Jamaica
Isaac
Isabella sorry Oh which was curated by
Tim behringer um Angela and Forrester
our senior curator of printed drawings
here at the center along with its
associated publication to which she
really made very important contributions
in terms of her research
more recently courtney has contributed
to British art studies and innovative
online journal published by the center
and our partner institution the Paul
Mellon Centre for studies of British art
in London we congratulate Courtney on
her new position we look forward to
collaborating in wonderful ways with dia
under your stewardship it will be an
honor and a pleasure but most especially
this evening we welcome you as the
moderator for this superb panel and I
hand the evening to you I became a
fellow twentieth-century art in the
building in across the street from Earth
and so we did incredibly special to me
to be here particularly among friends
I'd also like to thank Miko because not
only is Mego an alum and as I am but she
is also the designer of four generations
which i think is an amazing
so hopefully because of her wonderful
leadership and the design object Oh
upside down all right so I'd like to
start and we're going to chief
introduction so that we can really get
to the meat of the day and everyone here
had so much to say and so much to offer
I will start here with Susan Colin Susan
is in addition to being here
as an assistant dean in the Yale College
she is also the author of mounting
frustration a book that still fans right
now is my favorite book Wow out of our
history for this year mostly because
it's the only one that I've had time to
read and I look forward to the ways that
you will won't really give us more
information about it given that we also
have William T Williams here is included
in the book student x2 Susan is Pamela
Joyner and Pamela as you know is the
collector for whom this book was
compiled her unparalleled collection of
artists who were working largely in
abstraction is how I came to this
project but it is also what time many of
us together in this room I look here at
our publisher Greg Miller whom I'd like
to say hello to as a reminder that we
really came together as a group all of
the artists began to interact all of the
writers began to interact because of
Pamela Joyner and writer Frieda so I
would love to hear more about how that
collection its impetus as well as how
its expanded in the months since the
book has merged William T McWilliams the
subject of one of our many strains of
the conversation today is a 1968
graduate of the school of art Williams
is also the subject of a major solo
exhibition that will open on April 7th
in New York at the Michael Rosenfeld
gallery so I invite you all to not only
think about the work that is here but
also the work that you will get to see
that spans a good portion of his career
and I'm just under a month
I am wildly anticipating this exhibition
so I look forward to talking to you and
having you tell us more about how this
work had a genesis here at Yale and
Kevin Beasley who which has recently
come from the West Coast at an amazing
show at the hammer will talk to us about
more recent adventures at the Yale
School of Art for which he matriculated
in 2012 so please join me in welcoming
all to the panel
[Applause]
so I want to start with you partially
because I want I want to get it said so
I'd like you to put us into 1966 to 1968
in New Haven a few streets you streets
away on Temple Street down the streets
on York you know what was the schools
are like between 66 and 68 what was it
like for an abstract painter
specifically well the school was divided
to two camps there were about five
biggest things and most of the other
paintings were abstract painters most
people are engaged in formalism which
was the going fair for the department it
was exciting
it was challenging there were a lot of
very very good artists in the program
and what generated I think the energy is
you had 24-hour use of the studios and
most people were there 26 hours so yeah
it has it's incredible energy that was
going on and most of the graduates that
I came out with her still very good
friends and most of them had long
careers and are still working and I
suspect that Kevin will be part of that
group of wealth
as his career goes on if you recently
told me that when you came that mal held
held out his hand to you and said
welcome I've been waiting for you and
that Jack tour cop who was the chair at
the time of the painting department
really pushed you he gave you a reading
list from the rudolph building he said
get in there and just you know start
reading is that what the department felt
like to you at the time well I was
coming from Pratt which was an art
school so there was some background
I'll tell the day I got on campus
he was there and lilies that I've been
waiting for you the people who have
written letters of recommendations were
he was very familiar with he liked the
work and within the week he had given me
a reading list that was impossible it
was just not possible to do and he would
each week come and give me another
reading list and he said next week was
only disgusting
so I spent probably goodness a good five
hours a day in the library and the
wonderful thing is in the bottom of the
rudolph building was the art library so
a situation where i was able to go into
the library and catch up on what I need
to know and then walk upstairs to the
top floor to the studio to work the rest
of the time window was here the school
the largest school of architecture had
not split we still want and we're
sharing the building that have been
sharing space so there really was a more
holistic understanding between the two
disciplines and the library really read
them together Kevin did you have a
similar experience were there people who
thought of themselves as abstract
painters in the way that were common
hild
might have when you tried I take it you
arrived in 2010 yeah not to my
recollection in terms of falling under
the label of an abstract painter I felt
like the time that you know I was in the
sculpture Department and so I was on
Edgewood and I didn't go to the painting
department that often unless it was to
see friends or go to a crit and so there
was a little bit of separation but I
felt like really the way that people's
practices we're evolving we're around
like urgency
certain issues that I think that the
work could kind of speak to so you had a
wide range of what people were doing I
would say abstraction was a predominant
way that people were approaching dealing
with these kinds
issues or things that they were bringing
up the network but like one of my like
most favorite painters was figurative
painter but I think that what was
remarkable or what is remarkable about
her work in particular Jennifer Packer
is the kind of the way that she handles
paint the abstraction within that when
you focus in so I think that there's a
lot of the way that the sort of
processes and techniques and way that
people are approaching certain certain
subject matter it's like a free-for-all
all of these things are available all of
these approaches are available and the
conversations are really tough and
really hard because you have to sort of
in some way justified to yourself first
why you're doing what you're doing and
then do that in front of others yeah
maybe not does that justification you
know would you have described yourself
as an abstract sculptor when you were
here was that a part of the
justification or would you never touch
that terminology do you even call
yourself the sculptor now I should have
a sculptor yeah okay I'm deeply invested
in and what sculpture does for you know
space to the body for experience but in
terms of abstraction I think that that
is the most sort of viable way for me to
to deal with I don't know surreal it's
hard to find the language you know I
think it's you know it's really
important for me that my practice in the
studio mirrors my experience on the
street just you know interacting with
friends the way that I build
relationships with people the way that I
think about context and I think of
abstraction is the way that my brain is
kind of wired in the way that I
see things so I feel like I'm in some
way trying to process these things
through other forms that may not already
be established that in some way I'm
trying to sort of investigate those
things and and yeah and really try to
create something out of that yes I think
like maybe I had more of an aversion to
representation than I did a an approach
to extraction or one that would sort of
claim abstraction so was that something
that you that mirrors your experience in
any way did you you came here at a
moment when abstract art was visible in
major museums but it was also connected
right well you know we're you having
conversations which work often held
about a politic of abstraction that
needed to define itself against
figuration and you also you took art
history courses with that a discussion
that that leaked out of the art school
into the art history department across
the tree well the discussions
abstraction verse and figuration was
certainly going on the interesting thing
is my background is mostly figurative
teachers cats
Pearlstein gave lot of men these were
people who were I mean dedicated to the
figure and have been and continue to be
so I had a kind of dual background in
terms of having those skills to be able
to do that but having made a choice I
did not want to do that
there was no psychic place for me inside
of figuration and what I needed was a
place that I could exist in a place that
allowed me to talk about or speak to
those kinds of issues about humanity and
figuration was not doing it for me
nor was formalism at that particular
time so my struggle in graduate school
was one the body of information the
formulas dialogue that was going on
having to engage in that but
the work was pulling away from that more
and more and more the minimalist
movement was not for me either I was
just I was interested in the maximum
movement as much as possible and
overload and kind of emotional overload
in the work so your question is
basically it was a hard time for me
primarily because of what I was doing
and the way that my approach to doing
things so it's very conscious of that
but it would put me on the outside the
political climate at that particular
time 1968 was one of the question of
whether extraction was viable whether it
had enough whether there was any content
and whether it spoke to Kevin's idea of
the street or things that were going on
politically in the country if you for me
it was the idea that a metaphor
sometimes it's much more powerful than
an advert description of something a
work of art I think has to exist over a
long period of time rather than just
being popular at a specific time
so the aspiration again was to make
something that would last past that
moment past 1970 or past that particular
kind of expression that was going on in
the young one with you both Kevin and
Bill are in your collection and a [ __ ]
also featured prominently in the book
when you have looked at both of their
work I assumed that you collected Bill
first is that true that's true yeah and
I assumed in that in collecting bill
first that you've already interested in
abstraction in some ways I mean did you
come to him and say wow I just liked the
painting
we do have a dedicated plan to collect
an abstract artist well I actually was
very familiar with bills work long
before I owned it and I really you know
absolutely fell in love with the work
what no flat image tells you about
Bill's work I mean especially that body
of work and then the subsequent theory
is this notion of the maximum because
first of all you know we really endeavor
to collect work that is quickl right
work the changes of conversation and
work that will endure so that's one
baseline and so I look at that work and
I say it is a game changer but what's
not obvious from those reproduced images
is the feathering in the detail and I
mean I find them I find that particular
aspect of the practice I find it
romantic I find that it is you've
thought evoking I mean it just is it's
just a mess bill McMahon Verizon work so
but by the time I was able to acquire
Bill's work we were really on a
particular path to focus on abstraction
although I mean it's clear from the
slides we will depart from that
narrative in some ways as well because
we're a private collection not a museum
we can do what we want all right so so
we're drawn to what we're drawn to but
but we were the discipline is a focus on
abstraction and I actually see I can
make an argument that Bill's work is in
direct dialogue with Kevin's work which
the work we own of Kevin's is dense
using Kevin's language but it has a
multi-layered multifaceted density and
it is also mission critical mission
critical Wow
feel like we should all be in white
gloves ready to get to work and how then
do you describe the rest of your
collection relative to how you do have
artists of generate different
generations in the collection do you do
you now say to yourself I would like to
see every single painter I would like to
see every single sculptor that is doing
X or do you still are you guided by a
feel like is it
does that have something to do with the
way that you approach this work you know
I wish I could consume everything that's
out there and digest everything that's
out there but but I can't we do have I
mean we're just drawn to certain a
certain kind of aesthetic we love what
we love and we're always aspiring to go
deeper in what it is and who it is that
we love so I mean we have both tensions
going on in the collection and the only
way to reconcile you know both of those
intuitions is to try to do what my MBA
training requires that I do which is to
make a plan and make a budget and make a
target and try to say you know color
within the lines
that's a harvest plan but I always but I
always step outside of those parameters
but we do try to establish parameters
that apply your collection is
particularly rich in mid to late 1960s
work and this is really the jumping-off
point in some ways for for your books to
them how did you get to that period what
what drew you and I have a copy here of
mounting frustration which is excellent
again you take us through a history of
abstraction but you
so not and I think the conventional ways
moving that you approach this poker case
studies so it is arguably a book that is
along the exhibition histories model as
well but lucky for us you are using
exhibitions that have not been studied
extensively nor have they really been
teased apart to understand their nuance
tell me how you get to this project and
why is it so rooted in this moment in
the sixties well the late 1960s and
early 70s were a period in which museums
changed dramatically you can even say
which is what I argue in the book that
it was a period of transformation that
marked a new era and an era that we are
now a part of it was an era assured in
by artists who have been excluded from
the major museums who wanted in
primarily artists of color
african-american artists women artists
and it was a period in which museums
were reexamining or forced to reexamine
the basic premises upon which they had
been founded and the basic
constituencies which they envisioned
themselves serving and so I was drawn to
that period in a way because it was a
cliff and I you know and I've been
giving book talks for the past year but
I've actually never really thought about
it in this way until just this moment
that there was a history written of the
Museum of Modern Art that came out I
think in 1971 called good old modern by
Russell lines many of you are probably
familiar with it and there was a history
of the Metropolitan Museum called
merchants and masterpieces which also
came out right around 1970 1971 and
[Music]
though both of those books end with this
statement of uncertainty that museums
are somehow hanging in the balance their
relevance is being called into question
their their honorific place in society
is being called into question and so I
think on some level I was challenging
myself to pick up the gauntlet
and really look at you know what that
transformation was during those years
and and the transformation the main
transformation I think with many
transformations were twofold one at
during this period when various
constituents were engaged in processes
of trying to gain entree into the museum
there were some successes and there were
were there was some lack of success lack
of sustained engagement with
constituencies of color and one parallel
development was the creation of
culturally what we call culturally
specific or culturally grounded museums
and those museums still exist and some
have become very important for example
the studio Museum which bill was
involved in in founding back in 1968 and
this system that we are now part of it
didn't exist before the early 1970s it
came into being during that period and
yet in our own era we I believe most of
us who were in the museum field see this
as normal and the other big shift is
that museums began taking their public
role and their engagements with broad
audiences much more seriously than they
had before prior to this period the
visitors to museums would have been
fewer and much less diverse and museums
were more like temples than educational
institutions and so this redefinition of
the museum as an educational institution
really came about in the early 70s
coincidentally I happen to be a teenager
in the 1970s
and that's when I had my first
involvement in museums I did a high
school apprenticeship at the
Metropolitan and and that was my first
exposure and so when I began delving
into this history
I was passionately interested in
understanding the period that really
shaped and gave form to the institution
that existed when I began and entered
the field one of the best things that I
think about Buddhism is that as you read
through you realize that if you were
going to write a new kind of artistry
about this period or really any other
that your primary sources have to shift
to matter and one of this is that you
really rely on that you know I think as
artists ourian's we've all views to some
degree but there is you know there are
no rules for this I also tell my
graduate students that I have never been
asked to nor will I ever be asked to
sign the human subject agreement that if
I were working in Physiology all you
have to do and yet you know I interview
artists like they like heaven all the
time and there is no protocol between if
there's no you know record of decorum
there's no standing agreement that I
will not you know in any way trespass
that relationship one of the things that
I thought was a real strength of your
book was that you know you do take on
the words of artists like Lee Williams
what was it like working with him and
talking to the offenders as well as
talking about look-alikes you feel maybe
you want to go what was it like for you
bill I was I was just kind of a maze of
its person I think was a lecturer in
more you home first matter of time she
came up to me and introduced herself
yeah was at the here now conference yes
yeah then 10 words she said can I
interview you and I was so taken back by
that
in terms of someone one wanting to do it
but also that she knew my name and had
an interest in doing it
father fearless was um it was
interesting to him because you know her
her interest is slightly different than
my interest as an artist and she forced
me to think about things in the context
of what she was interested in I'm still
kind of digesting her quote in the book
a little bit but should be me that
should be police don't know yeah now
straight ahead it's always for me
speaking with art historians and people
that are on the other side of the things
always interesting because it's it's
word based and as a painter painting is
not word based it it's about the tactile
stuff it's a sensuous world and it's
very difficult to find the words to talk
about that sensuous world that painting
is about I think when I go to the
museums and look at paintings it's
probably different than what the
curators are looking at or what our
historians are looking at I tend to be
want to be six inches from the painting
you know the guards go crazy when I do
it but I'm more interested in kind of
what the arts did what's under what's
over the kind of sensuous movement the
consistency of the pain that has been my
my involvement now that's slightly
different than a sculptor
when Kevin talked about the space before
and how it exists and the body
relationship to it it's a kind of
different experience can I just respond
to that for a minute before because the
thing that really was so powerful to me
about talking with you is the way in
which you took me into your experience
and the way in which you you you talked
about your your aspirations and your
accomplishments and your struggles as an
artist in the confrontation of materials
and in the application of materials and
I was laughing when Courtney first
answered a question because I
interviewed the Iceland interview bill
Twice first time when I went to
transcribe the tape I discovered that
nothing had been recorded which was a
tragedy
but that was okay because it gave me an
opportunity to go back and when I went
back I brought a group of students with
me I was teaching at University of
Missouri st. Louis at the time and we
did a studio visit with Bill where he
generously you know talked about his
development as an artist and showed the
students all kinds of work from all
different areas and and and shared with
them what it meant for him and mistakes
for him as an artist and I think that
for my students to hear to hear you talk
with such intensity about your process
was a revelation for them and I think
that it enabled them to understand that
the seriousness of what it means to make
decisions as an artist that there are no
default settings that every decision has
to be made and that every decision is in
some way going to affect the viewers
experience of that work and is going to
have impact on conscious levels and on
unconscious levels visceral levels and
you know I physically so on it was great
to be able to interview you twice sorry
Kevin thank you could you know Pamela
would you be willing to tell us a little
bit about your interaction with artists
in a kind of one on
relationship I think that you know Susan
and I sit on the artist or but I we but
we also sit a bit on the critical side
bill and Kevin sit you know as artists
even though bill is also written you
know as the collector I don't know where
the there's not a boundary for you
either right and ice but I think
actually you've explored the space is
that the collector is allowed to explore
to great depth tell us about the ways in
which you go about having one-on-one
relationships with artists so that's you
know sort of a multi-faceted phenomenon
I won't say that it's a process because
it's organic it happens how it happens
I'm actually in my third reading of
Susan's book and it's in part because
you know the collection is really it
does have its genesis around the
generation of artists working
abstraction working an abstraction of
which Bill is one and I don't know if
you remember this bill but must have
been about eight or nine years ago Mary
Schmidt Campbell had a breakfast at her
house and you were there Mel Edwards was
there and was it Jack or was it Sam
Gilliam there was the third person I
think was said with Sam and this what
was so striking to me about that
conversation was the red part a between
everyone that was very clear that these
were professionals who had great regard
one for the other though they work in
very very different ways and that they
have had decades of interaction that
still are ongoing to this day and in
some ways that was for the genesis of
the way I thought about this book it
actually began to materially inform how
we collect because now we actually look
for artists who are connected one to the
other within their generation so you
mentioned Jennifer Packer I think that's
really interesting that you have a
dialogue with her and interest in what
she does although what you do is very
different and so I think it's perfectly
fine for artists to work singularly by
themselves in a room
with no human interaction but that tends
to be not what we collect because we are
an activist collection as you mentioned
Courtney our mission really is to try to
bring forward what Susan points out in
her book and help to you know
institutionalize the reframing of a
particular aspect of our history and so
getting to know artists personally is
really important for us it's hard and it
actually does impact your ability to
maintain objectivity about the art and
I'm okay with that because you know
Kevin just was at our residency in
Sonoma and the artists stand alone and
it's spectacular but part of my
interaction with Kevin and golnaz and
too much wine on a Saturday night and my
husband's wine cellar gives me insight
about what the art is where it comes
from where it fits and so that's really
important so we we enjoy getting to know
artists personally and we really started
getting serious about the collection
about 15 years ago when we got to know
Richard Mayhew seriously and that's just
informed our process ever since when I
first met you Pamela
you've had so much art history knowledge
you have it's great library you were
constantly talking to me and I kept
saying you know I get paid for this and
you know we can't top our history all
the time I had Valentines one of the
things that I thought was so interesting
was that once you told me where your art
history came from I realized this is
what was different about it this is
actually what was interesting that
Pamela and Fred her husband had really
been influenced by Richard Mayhew a
painter who said these are the books
that I've read this is how I approach
painting these are the skill sets that I
have this is the way in which I go and
look at institution and that was you
know that's really radically different
to be innocent
you were trained in the Atelier and yet
you didn't learn to paint you learned
the history of painting and that wait I
think that that still fairly intact in
many ways in the way that you talk about
$1 yeah no I mean we really approach it
exactly in that way and also in part
because while there have always been
curators or art historians who were
knowledgeable about african-american
artists and artists of African descent
you couldn't dial 1-800 in this area
there weren't people specialized in this
area so we had to cobble together our
own resources and they came from all
over but they they mostly came from
interacting directly with the artists
who had you know just treasure trove of
stories and for instance God would say
as someone who I think an art historian
could spend years with because he just
knows so many stories that I think have
not been recorded and so if the
interaction is just very important for
us that would be an interesting person
in this context as well because he is a
graduate of the art school from 1993 and
though he has largely been photo based
he is also someone who records by either
his photographs or his previously good
texts but now his blog and his web page
the goings on other artists regardless
of of media so there is a way that
you're absolutely right that to know May
is not necessarily to be interested in
photography but to be interested in a
wider spectrum of our gardens Kevin tell
me have you read Suzan slogan this is
not a test
okay history in any way affects you in
the same way for for those of us years
there lived it to some degree or who are
actively researching and writing
about it I haven't read the book I'll
pay you later for it well I think you
know a lot it's like all the time
like I feel like I'm able to sort of
reap the benefits of a lot of the sort
of work that's been done during this
time you know like one of the biggest is
is Bill scarring the studio museum
studio program like I'm a beneficiary of
that and still reaping benefits from
that time there and I think that you
can't avoid as a black artist you can't
avoid those kinds of or ignore the the
history that it sort of led you to you
know one enter into an institutional
collection or to be able to engage with
the kinds of curators that you want to
be able to engage with who are doing
biennials who are travelling all over
the place and you know putting your work
in the context of other people's work
both you know generationally and then
with your peers I feel like it's it's
it's vital to actually consider those
things because you know when I think
about the space or the context for
instance the work is you can't avoid the
history of the way that the space has
been now the way that the space has been
used just as an example the work that I
just recently did for the hammer is in
part considering the fact that the
architecture was constructed for da
Vinci codex so thinking about my own
practice in the conversations that
happen in my studio relating to you know
a high Renaissance sculpture Bernini and
Baroque and then taking the kind of
social issues within you know la in San
Francisco
and sort of collapsing all of that into
one space is so much about the kind of
work and the possibility in being able
to do
things in these spaces when given an
opportunity to do it so in some way I
think that my practice very specifically
is always trying to sort of mind some
aspects of a certain social history that
I'm interested in that I'm constantly
indebted to but then also find where my
my direct relationship is to that so
bringing aspects of my own life my own
practice and my own approach into that
conversation yeah I don't know if that
really gets to the book but I I feel
like this conversation would not be
complete unless I also told my bill
William Santa I have every but I only
have only Sherman so the the second time
that I met bill was the first time that
I interviewed him and I actually went
because I wanted to talk to him about
another painter but I really wanted to
hear him talk about the whole period and
that picture was Greg bowling frank
bowling who is a British artist she is
really you know the standard bearer I
think for the modernist
cabin of 20th century British art but in
some ways strangely enough he is he
links many of us together here bill is a
friend of Frank Frank is a an artist
that is in the collection of the joiners
mature traders and he is someone that
Susan mentions in her book but he is
also someone who would come here as a
critic in the 60s and 70s when he was
living in New York not a legend here we
are in the middle of the Yale Center for
British art and I just wondered if we
could talk a bit about that
anglo-american exchange by way of
someone like Frank Frank one Frank is a
terrific painter when I met him I guess
1968 his studio is two blocks below mine
Frank knocked on my door one day and
introduced himself and
we became kind of friends there after he
had a very different approach one of the
things that was remarkable about the
work is the light in his paintings was
unlike any light I have seen in a
painting and I took that to mean because
he was from South America that he had
experience and why in a way that I never
had he was generous to loan me a
painting one day I was in his studio and
I said Frank I really really like that
painting can I take it home and he said
sure and I took it home and it stayed in
the studio about a year and a half and
one day he knocks on the door he says I
want my painting back I want my paying
back get more British dresses so what I
learned from the painting about Frank he
had a wonderful touch in terms of the
application of paint he had an
extraordinary eye for color and he was
undoubtedly one of the great British
painting paintings of that generation
and what was on top of that was the
ability to write about contemporary art
his writing was wrong and I say that
what I mean by that he was writing from
a very very British perspective about
American art and he was writing from a
artist from Guyana who went to England
and then to this country with that as a
as a context also for his writing which
was very different than my perspective
and artist that he was writing about but
the importance of the writing is because
of that because of his perspex coming
from that background and our perspective
in terms of making New York
he was really vital during that period
in terms of his insistence upon a
certain kind of hour
so we thought so
I actually I can't address the question
of Frank's writing because I haven't
read a lot of Frank's writing but I
would agree with bills assessment and
this actually is making me think you
know in some detail about what we do we
own Frank fairly deeply Frank is one of
the first artists we bought in the
collection we own each of the major four
series that he has worked in throughout
his lifetime and even though the visual
of bills work versus Frank's work versus
Sam Gilliam's work is all very different
they have a through-line for me in terms
of what we find to be attractive about
the work we like people who are great
colorist bill is a great colors Sam is a
great color as Frank is a great colorist
Richard Mason was a great colorist
Frank's paintings I would categorize
overall as rougher those are more
refined Sam's are more sporadic but the
the understanding of material
materiality and the sense that the
material is evocative is a through
strand and all of the work so I mean I
mean this is interesting for me to hear
myself say because I mean I could
probably you know go through now half a
dozen or 10 other painters there in the
collection and I would say these they
are the standard bearers for what it is
we find compelling from an aesthetic
point of view Kevin by the time that
that I arrived here and then you arrived
here the idea of the Britishness that
that bill describes which i think is
absolutely on point had I feel that
suddenly like it is kind of you know
dissolved of it no Lynette Yatim baracci
is represented by a
upstairs in this building either Julian
the filmmaker who is in Pamela's
collection but it had also visited this
campus and his work had been shown at
the Yale University art gallery
Sonya boys and other British artists
have been shown here Gingka show nebari
just had an exhibition here inside the
BAC in the last year you know I don't
know anymore if you and I necessarily
recognize those artists as British with
a capital D in the same way do you do
you immediately go upstairs and see
Lynette painting and think British or do
you just you know see painting yeah I
just keep painting like very
transformational painting and the time
to when like you know when I was in
school just you know to paint and you
know so like so the art school for
instance it'sa stations between
departments and this was my experience I
don't know how it sort of evolved now
but I remember the Dean Rob store at the
time explaining to everyone very
specifically why the distinctions were
important and the distinctions in you
know there at a time - when graduate
programs are sort of putting all of
these departments just comes throwing
everyone into one pool and you sort of
learn from different kinds of people you
could have someone who works primarily
in video coming to your studio and be
your adviser of your painter and these
kinds of things but at Yale if it was
really sort of specific that the heads
of the departments were deeply invested
in in these kind of decorations not as
like a dogmatic thing but more as an
educational approach that if if you were
a painter and you declare yourself a
painting that you could go directly into
your part of the department and you
could have a very critical conversation
about painting about the history of
painting and you knew that there would
be someone in your depart
that you could carry that conversation
with and that was the same thing in the
sculpture Department and the same thing
in photography and in graphic design and
I felt that that that was kind of the
sort of overriding conversation was how
people sort of identified with the
mediums that they were choosing so if
you were in the painting department and
you were doing something more sculptural
one he had a smaller studio than the
sculpture Susan so it clearly was it was
proven to be difficult to be able to to
make the kind of ambitious work that a
sculpture student would be able to make
but he then would face criticism and and
constructively in all of these different
ways and that would happen in the
sculpture Department people who would
choose to paint very specifically to
make paintings that that conversation
would then you would have to sort of you
know you'd have to like stand to the
test or something but I think that that
made this this idea about everything
that you do is a decision made that more
it made that more apparent and so the
way that people you know were working
was these decisions very conscientious
and if you weren't then someone was
going to hold you accountable for that
so I guess what yeah you know it's funny
I arrived here today and the first thing
that I wanted to do really speaks to
that kind of sense of being held
accountable and recently Yale acquired
and installed a mural by
so dearly Donald or DITA who is also in
the joiner to Fraser collection and I
wanted to go and see it because I felt
if this was not only a statement about a
great painter I hope that you all have
Gandhi's to see this mural as a style
College and that you will continue going
back to see it but I also felt like it
was it was Yale making a real statement
about painting of an abstraction about
where we stand with artists across the
world at this moment and I wonder if
Susan beam is probably a far more than
any of the rest of us on stage here -
really if this feels like something is
were holding yeah absolutely and I think
you so can put it open in just a slide
and I actually made some notes so that I
could also share with you all some of
ideally Donald OTT
ideas I think that you know we've been
talking mostly about the late 1960s in
the early 70s and that was a time period
in which there were a lot of arguments
about abstraction
it was very contested and arguments that
what abstraction was what his potential
was was it over arguments about the
relative merits of abstraction and
figuration and I think that during that
time certainly in the dominant popular
discussions abstraction was viewed as
something that had a certain kind of
abstract paintings had a certain kind of
internal coherence that they were
universes unto themselves and there were
ideas that had been inherited from
decades earlier ideas and high modernism
that had to do with painting distilling
itself down to its purest essence and
distilling itself down to and for those
of you who study art history and art
these are very familiar ideas that
painting distilling itself down to the
qualities that are intrinsic to the
medium itself and kind of purging it of
itself of everything else those ideas
were inherited from Clement
in Bergen popularized in you know
throughout the 60s 70s and even into the
80s by Hilton Kramer the Chiefs art
critic at the New York Times and so I
think that abstraction now as we're
talking about it is something quite
different it's a much more open field I
think you know everyone who's talking
about here is talking about it in a way
that has is coming from a place of much
greater freedom rather than constraint
and OD Leo Dida's work is I think
astonishingly it's a gift
an astonishing gift to the Yale campus
not a literal gift but it's a gift of a
Yale campus all right because of the way
that OD Lee's vocabulary as an artist
interacts so specifically with the site
in which the piece was made and Nico can
we see the slide of Ezra Stiles College
so what you can see here is it's a wall
painting that is in two parts and it um
it has a there's another unit bring that
one okay so the piece is abstract but at
ebb but it doesn't have a strict
geometry and it has a very varied
palette but it's not a prescriptive
palette and it's not a predictable
palette Oh dealing is very interested in
the theories of color interaction of
Josef Albers which is you all know who
was the director of the design
department here during the 1950's but so
he's interested in how colors interact
with each other optically and
experientially but not necessarily a
systematic approach to color Oh dealing
is also very interested in and was
influenced by the work of Sol with a
wall painter very well known to Yale
Yale has probably one of the largest
collections of Lewis work in the world
and the sense that
the color in this piece gives the piece
of certain vitality but is always held
by the form is one of the one of the
characteristics that I think makes it
both dynamic and present in the moment
as well as having a certain kind of
monumentality and the monumentality of
the piece to me resonates very strongly
with the architecture of Ezra Stiles
College if I may can I just read to you
a little of Oh Billy's words he says he
said in developing this piece I wanted
to address the particulars of this
building and to add to an ongoing
process of opening out to the community
at large the skylight windows and that
renovated area in the common room has
beautiful skylight windows were a
significant aspect of consideration for
my designs which counters the initial
feeling of enclosure fixed within the
monochromatic coloring of dark wood
found in the front of the building
the skylight windows were simply
stunning in presence and purpose I came
to understand and structural intentions
of the skylights as a passageway adding
natural light into the common room and
allowing the energies from the interior
of this building to move outward and
cominging with life in the surrounding
rubble masonry pre gothic exterior of
Ezra style okay up ultimately the design
drawing and color of my wall painting
was made to give force and reason to
this idea of rising upward and outward
so Oh Delia was very conscious of the
fact that this is a room used by young
people it's a room where people do
different things they study they hang
out they socialize he's very conscious
of Yael a college campus as being a
transient site where people move through
the space they don't live there forever
they come there temporary residents and
then they move on in his words you know
upward and outward and he I think was
very conscious of wanting to create a
piece that was going to have ongoing
interest for people who would see
literally every day yeah she said I
can't believe you brought a full circle
to be able to both consider AB
contemporary abstract painting and
perhaps also rockin that's wonderful
maybe this is the moment that we open
our close conversation to our audience
here I'm sure that that I'm not the only
person that is bursting with questions
completely I think that we have
microphones that are coming down on
either side so if I may ask you to wait
until the microphone reaches you just
signal if you like it if not I'm happy
to go on names and items several in the
office Oh Joan I want to congratulate
you on the appointment to the Gators
thank you how does that go about getting
to the point I mean you know that the
director whom I've known tangentially
for a number of years along with his
board chair rang up and invited me and
you know I had to involve din a lot of
institutions and I said on a lot of
boards and I not known for having a lot
of free time and I did have to study it
and after meeting a number of the board
members and spending some time with the
staff it became clear to me the extent
to which the getti particularly in its
research capability is a world-class
institution and the board felt that some
of the things I'm interested in could
augment their activities in that
specific area and I'm one again
hearkening to you know this MBA training
I need a job description and so when I
got a job description that I liked I
decided I would join the board
like that I'm sure you have a question
we have one here thank you very much for
that I really enjoyed it and I'm very
interested in Kevin that you made a
reference of scale as being a factor in
just a studious might be allotted and I
wondered if all of you from your
different perspectives might speak to
how to scale factors into how you see
these works I don't know playing into
what you choose to collect or how you
choose to represent or think about how
abstraction that you hold excessively
well I mean it just strikes me that a
lot of the work that's being made today
by contemporary artists it's big you
know some of the pieces that we own of
Kevin are monumental I'm not sure how
they're going to fit into the space that
we have to offer one we just
commissioned we just installed two weeks
ago my husband told me we would never
move I'm glad I wasn't there to witness
it we hung it from the ceiling Kevin and
five other guys need to move this work
that I think it's the largest single
piece of work you've ever made it's nine
by fourteen feet and it is monumental
but I do say and there's not necessarily
a direct correlation between size and
the notion of work being iconic but we
really do endeavor in our collecting
efforts to find whether the work is by a
young artist or a very senior artist
we're really looking for things that are
iconic within the context of that
practice and in today's world a lot of
that is large
put you in there
my question is for Susan as dean of the
arts is as your style the abstract
college and nature of the Yale colleges
have so much art in them all around
campus does that affect student life in
any way I don't know if it affects
student life yes tell me how it has tell
honored you don't know having an
abstract piece having art just Oh having
art oh my god having art is around Kate
oh yeah I mean so there are a lot of
really exciting artists I mean okay yeah
in my dreams
Morrison Styles would be galleries I
mean oh all right bass is feeling so
incredible that um you know there are
any number of artists and I'm not going
to name them now but any number of
artists who I think their work would
just look absolutely spectacular in any
of those spaces and you know for example
the dining hall well Cal named one
artist I'm envisioning and forgive me
but Pamela I'm envisioning an
installation by Jorge Pardo of glass
blown lamps you know hanging from the
ceiling hundreds of colored glass blown
hand-blown laughs Sara Z of an alum of
Yale who makes sculptures that look like
exploded objects you know her work would
look fabulous in the stairwell so I love
the way the colleges look and I think
the renovation was just absolutely
spectacular so yes I think that that you
know some work works better in some
spaces and others there also are a lot
of portraits that hang in in Ezra and
Morse in the head of colleges homes in
particular you know are the portraits of
Ezra and I think it's wife the one of
him really stands out so yeah I mean the
work because it's it actually
would be recreated in another space so
in that sense it's not strictly
site-specific but it was conceived for
that space thank you so many thing to
think about in what you said and but I'm
still thinking about Frank bowling
talking about American freezing in a
British way something I try to do quite
a lot and I'd love to know that then
when you talk about abstract painting it
when you paint abstract painting are you
inhabiting a national space is American
abstract painting different from
abstract painting in Italy or in Britain
and void of the discourse around it and
then within that in African American
abstract painting as phase within
American painting more space within
global painting that was what what a
nation was a nation feed into an
abstraction where they meet this was one
of my graduate exam questions so this is
really a question I'll address one small
part of that I would suggest to you and
I will quote the editor of our book that
race is a very bad lens through which to
view art art is art abstraction is
abstraction it should be judged based on
the merit of what it is who made it will
always be any work of art has the
signature of the maker in it but you
have to evaluate the artists a
standalone phenomenon I want that
answers that question in some ways
because I think you already know what I
think about this but I do think that it
is important as we sit here in an
institution that is in many ways like to
vote into a certain nationalism but it
is also just as devoted to expanding
what that they have wants them to now be
something else I think it is important
to see Frank bowling
as British but I hope addicted is
important to understand his immigrant
status in New York and it specifically
New York II he was he did not go to the
rest of the country in that way but I
also think that I thought was very
interesting that bill describes him in
South America and that was that's like
telling for me because I immediately
wanted to say to bill but he is you know
he was born in Guyana before and
dependency was just from the empire that
doesn't have you know that has a broad
location and yet we are all right in a
way it is important particularly in the
way that the modern contemporary
material in this building is understood
to get the genesis of it so we need to
understand that someone like John Boylan
had to fight again you know essentially
the imperialism of American abstract
painting that was being brought to
London and was being sort of
superimposed on to a much longer
tradition of abstract painting that are
in existence to then get to why someone
like Frank bowling felt that he needed
to come to the state and that not only
did he need to come to the states needed
to go to New York
and he needed to go around and meet
people like Bill Williams and that they
stayed in in conversation has as much to
do I think a rap about why being British
at that moment was both incredibly
constitutive for him so he was writing I
think you're absolutely right that he
was writing about American art from this
very British perspective but I think he
desperately wanted to be a part of
second generation abstraction in that
writing so part of that was writing
himself into the story that's happening
with you all at the same time well there
also if you remember if you think that
John Walker came over at the same time
there was an invasion of British artists
at that point
hawkman Hoffman and there is a slightly
different attitude in the work in the
case of say John Walker there is a
physicality and account of Romanticism
and in the way he he painted and it
seemed like the tradition that he was
now I think Pam's idea when you put an
overlay of race on work you're stepping
into a very difficult area because there
are nuances that have to be talked about
your experiences that have to be talked
about and sometimes we kind of shortcut
that abstraction is a home for artists
all over the world there is a form of
abstraction that probably exists in
every I just kept you know from New
Zealand they're abstract artists and it
John it allows us to into a work of art
and to be transformed when you stand in
front of a good abstract painting
there's no separation between you and
the painting you're not looking at
something you're experiencing that thing
and that's the most difficult thing to
have people do in a museum is to
experience the work of art as opposed to
look at a work of art if you've ever
gone to the met people spend about 10
seconds in front of something and then
they move on well that's that's just the
opposite of what my whole life is about
I think painters and sculptors and
artists are trying to get you to slow
down just a little bit and experience
something as opposed to look at
something and categorize it you know
it's almost like you you know you have
to get through this and you have to have
52 names it reminds me you know when you
send young high school junior high
school kids to the museum and you give
them a list of what they have to see and
you say well you know come back with 25
names and they get to 25 names in 25
minutes and they fill the assignment but
you
is the essential thing the reason you're
sending them to the museum which is to
have this experience that's outside of
what they normally do and what they
normally are engaged in for me as a
museum how do you slow people down how
do you get them to experience something
because it's that experience for being
when I was very young that transformed
me and probably allowed me to become an
artist and aside I went to high school
on 51st and Lexington Avenue in Museum
of Modern Art was on 54th just all fifth
so we're talking about five blocks
between those two experiences the museum
on Arad became an extension of our
classrooms there's we were taking there
constantly and taking there to the Met
as well and I think the more we can get
young people into the museum the better
and what I mean by that is physically
get them into the museum in heaven them
spend time with the object it's not
necessarily for them to know the the who
the artist is the date that it was made
what period is from it's just to have an
experience with objects and you know the
wonderful thing about the Yale art
gallery is it's free here which is very
different than going to the Met when you
have to pay 18 bucks or the modern or
whatever it is it's a free institution
the question is how do you get the
audience how do you develop this new
audience that's the that's what's going
to save my life and my experience and
the 50 years that I put into being an
artist is that new audience I'm sorry
I'm know going off here
usual don't don't give us the message I
I want to invite everyone here to
continue this conversation but let's do
so outside on the second floor in the
reception up that the center has Rachel
who will be provided with along with the
President and we would like all I want
to say in question we all Center for
British art I would like to today
present Salome and doctor his wife and I
would also like to thank you all for
coming and listening to us tonight thank
you
[Applause]
you
[Music]